stupid fat hurts
you excluded me from the movie destroy
the dragon you must touch
i got a little carried away there
the hobbit desolation of smog
or smack or whatever what does it
[ __ ] matter let me tell you right up
front i
hated the first hobbit with a passion of
the christ
just a major [ __ ] disappointment it
was like when i had sex with a jewish
girl it was like oh she doesn't believe
in jesus this is gonna be hot it's gonna
be exotic
but no it was just regular good sex
nothing special but this film i [ __ ]
loved it right off the bat
the directing and cinematography major
[ __ ] improvement
everyone's talking about the 48 frame
rate thingy and this time it
wasn't distracting it looked really good
like that
jewish girl peter jackson got his feet
wet with the first one he you know
probably got his dick wet too since he
lost a lot of weight what i loved about
this film was the whole time
i wasn't like yeah i remember lord of
the rings that was that was a good movie
it has its own separate feel it's its
own standalone thing but desolation of
smog is just a great
action adventure fantasy film like it
gets really
intense it's a moving picture like in
the first one i thought the dwarves were
so
[ __ ] boring like usually when i see a
[ __ ] i'm immediately entertained but
no no
no not with that film this time i really
enjoyed watching all of them i had a
great time hanging out with the little
guys how awesome would it be if the
dwarves made up with their small size by
having a huge
dick it's probably really hairy but
beautiful martin freeman
as bilbo baggins or should i say bimbo
[ __ ] oh
original humor martin freeman just
brings such whimsicalness and sincerity
to the performance and in this film they
get to show off how like bilbo is a
badass they should have called this the
hobbit
bilbo saves the dwarves asses repeatedly
and yet they don't give him much respect
still
granted he's only like in a fifth of
this film but the scenes with him are
like some of the best scenes in this
film and eve mckellen as
gandalf the grey he's barely in this
film and sort of just felt like gandalf
being
tanned off again not much more depth to
it but ian mckellen's really good at
being gandalf
i just wish they gave us a little more
to explore with the character i'd love
to see a movie with gandalf
like having a romantic love interest i'd
imagine to be a black girl because let's
face it out of all the characters
gandalf probably has the biggest dick
and my
favorite character orlando bloom as
legolas
orlando bloom [ __ ] love this guy
in lord of the rings yeah he was the
[ __ ] but he's kind of just that cool guy
with a bow and arrow in this film he's a
much more focused character you see that
he's got like a love interest you get to
meet the dude's father well i'm pretty
sure he's a homosexual
he just kicked so much ass like he was
already an
ass kicker like if there was an ass
around he would be kicking
that ass he's just he's ten times cooler
than he already was look i wouldn't suck
orlando bloomstick but i would
definitely suck
legolas dick evangeline lily is tariel i
always love watching a female character
kick some ass it's easier for me to
imagine my dominatrix fantasies
she's like a female equivalent to
legolas i can honestly see just a whole
spin-off movie about legolas and tario
and evangeline lilly
she's [ __ ] hot i would
[ __ ] her with those elf ears i prefer
she has them on
otherwise i'd just be flaccid kidding
not really
and richard armitage as thorin i love
his internal complexity
driven by what's right or is it greed
and power he's more of the leader i
enjoy
watching in a movie someone who you're
like should i trust this guy fully like
yes he's the leader but he obviously can
make some serious mistakes
like the jewish girl and of course
probably the best thing about this movie
benedict cumberbatch as smog without a
doubt
the best part of this film next to
legolas is the dragon i saw this in imax
3d and i swear it was like he was coming
out of the theater i like reached my
hand out to try and touch him
somehow i ended up groping the old lady
in front of me but whatever she probably
liked it the dude is like monologuing
the whole time the scenes between him
and bilbo were just fantastic
like smog is only like in the last 30
minutes or so and there's so much build
up to him
but damn they like under promise but
over [ __ ] deliver
and the effects are just so damn good on
him you're never pulled out by going uh
it looks a little fake like you are just
engrossed i don't know how benedict
cumberbatch does it man like
he made the dragon kind of sexy like if
i was a gay male dragon
i would have dragon sex with smog
i'd be on bottom and elijah would as
frodo he's not in this movie
as always the visual effects are
dynamite there's an exceptional
production design
and the action's just so badass there's
just one scene that deals with the river
and there's like orcs and the dwarves
and then and elves
it's just so exciting so fun you don't
want it to end and the whole time you're
constantly going
you see that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah this
movie turned me into a black guy
like legolas is just so badass in it
you're watching the whole time going god
i'm gonna suck his dick so bad
and i want tario to watch i really just
love the way this story moves it cuts
back and forth between several different
stories but each story is incredibly
engrossing i love how they all tie in
i know they've really redone a lot of
the story to have it tie in with lord of
the rings more and honestly
i love what they're doing i really enjoy
the tie-ins like a lot of time it had me
going
ah i see how that [ __ ] came to be that
[ __ ] like this movie is just so good
that you know that certain characters
are obviously
to live because those characters are in
lord of the rings but you'll completely
forget about that it'll be so intense
and the
danger will be felt like you'll be like
oh [ __ ] how is bilbo gonna get out of
this how the [ __ ]
is gandalf gonna get out of this and you
like fear for the lives of those you
don't know are gonna make it or not
i wonder if there's like dwarf gang
being porn i would love to masturbate to
that just for the experience not because
i want to do it consistently i mean who
knows i might really like it
last thing i gotta say watch it on imax
please do i saw this at citywalk dead
center seats
and it was worth every penny like the
taiwanese hooker i slept with last week
real fast i know this has nothing to do
with the movie but there are these
douchebags who are sitting in my seat
and keep in mind this is reserved
seating and these [ __ ] were refusing
to move and the
movie had already started like i got
into the argument with this guy who's
really split up our group like what the
[ __ ] do i care about my split group you
guys be talking the whole [ __ ] time
i'd rather split up your group if you
guys did talk the whole time i'd piss on
you so when i kicked the people out of
my seats there were these two people
sitting next to me
who were just like pissed off at me and
if you [ __ ] happen to be watching
this review
i hope you burn in hell and i hope satan
makes you suck his fiery [ __ ]
and i hope that hitler ass [ __ ] both of
you especially that woman who just
wouldn't
shut the [ __ ] up saying [ __ ] like you
just get into somewhere else
society these days she pulled the
society line on me and apparently where
they were sitting was also someone
else's seats and then they got kicked
out of the theater
so ha you [ __ ] you ruined the
first 10 minutes of this movie for me
now i'm not gonna piss on you i'm gonna
[ __ ] on you i'm gonna take a bunch of
fiber every day
in hopes that i will bump into you so i
can poop on you let me get straight to
the point here all in all i gotta say
the hobbit desolation of smog got it
super right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for the hobbit desolation of
smog
watch go ahead scroll that comment box
below and tell me which character out of
this franchise do you think has the
biggest dick and if you want to see more
episodes of straight to the point you
can click the link right here
i got a lot of videos a lot of [ __ ] you
can watch
because you know i want you to watch all
my videos
this is all i do i have no friends and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews is
out go to click on this button by my
dick to subscribe
that's right the dick subscribe
let me tell you something about this
little dragon
once he goes inside you he's gonna set
your [ __ ] on fire
is it gonna hurt probably
will it hurt me maybe but is it gonna be
worth it
probably not